[Music]
happy new year guys we hope you've had a
ah let's say a tolerable one but for
those of you looking for good news we've
got some
right here at trigonometry indeed
francis is going to get a haircut
constantine doesn't need a haircut
because he doesn't have any yeah i'm not
sure that's good news but we do have
good news for you which is
that we recorded about four or five
months ago
a very special interview between the two
of us you may remember
your regular view of the show one called
trigonometry destroys trigonometry where
we interview each other
and talk about the things that are
happening and the things we think will
be happening
now we recorded this video late in the
summer i think
and we are finally putting it out and
all you need to do to get access to it
is
hit the link in the description and sign
up to the mailing list and we will send
it to you
along with a few very interesting and
funny stories about the background to
the show
you guys are going to love it also those
of you who are on locals you will you
can have access to the video
but you won't get access to the cool and
interesting story so we recommend
everybody hit the link in the
description go there sign up to the main
list
and you will get access to and we won't
spam you with uh emails
all the time we promise you that
absolutely so come in sign up to the
mailing list it's
absolutely free and you'll get all this
amazing free content
yes and the content is us our
predictions for the rest of 2020 which
you can see how wrong or right we were
you can see what we thought about things
that were
happening and going to happen and you
get to hear about why we got cancelled
from our last studio in great
excruciating painful detail
we're not bitter